[Music]
hello oh good evening
are you the puberty fairy what did you
just call me the puberty Fair I'm the
hormone monster I'm just here to give
you a friend a nocturnal emission
I'll come into all these videos puberty
for boys is like the miracle of
ejaculation oh no that's the most I've
ever made and for girls for just a darn
ball of aging food last night I saw
Andrews penis and now you're worried
you're homosexual Nikki a man can touch
another penis so excuse me even kiss one
very lightly okay this might be somewhat
rare for you what are you saying that
most of the time I'm gonna like girls
and they won't like me back so I should
seize this opportunity yeah that makes
sense
everything's embarrassing everything is
so embarrassing
there's another slit in the back but
that's only for my birthday this kid
might be a genius get this girls are
horny - just as horny as guys suppose
you wanna shoplift lipstick you want to
listen to Lana Del Rey on repeat you and
a scream
[Music]
[Music]
here goes something i'm your genitals hi
I'm Jessie you know you're not scary
bill is that too far that part made me
uncomfortable yeah at the time it seemed
funny
no and I like [ __ ] up stuff like that
I know Netflix insisted on it really
[Music]